we were very fascinated have been for a
while
with the sort of social thrillers of the
70s the coolest trilogy of Clue all the
President's Men in the parallax view and
I think we live in a time that's really
ripe for taking that sort of social
anxiety and putting it through the mill
in the summer of 2009 not as research
just but just us living our lives we
were we had been out in LA and it's all
had just gotten out of the American Film
Institute wanted to direct and I wanted
to act but those aren't exactly jobs you
can just go out and get so we were
jobless and we were young and we were
reading a lot about anarchists
manifestos online and about the sort of
freaking world and we were intrigued and
so we we set off to have an adventure
and we packed backpacks and we went on
the road and we learned to Train hop and
we lived on organic farms and then met
people and lived with anarchist
collectives and then lived in squats and
we went back and forth across the
country and we went back to LA and kind
of made two movies in that same sort of
spirit another earth and sound of my
voice which were very handmade sort of
collectivist films and we couldn't
really shake the experience of that
summer still so we started writing about
it I think as a way to make sense of how
it opened us and thought it would be
more fun to embed it is the story the
idea oh I had this idea let's flesh this
out a little bit well in a 6-day writing
week we spent a lot of time just doing
homework with each other just you know
housekeeping so how are you feeling how
am I feeling what are you reading you
know what am I reading sharing those
kind of things with each other and then
when we feel like the tracks are clear
and clean we start sending the ideas
back and forth and they start so I think
they start like amoebas they're so
gelatinous they're so fragile that you
know we never write on the computer or
anything for months we spend just
passing the gelatinous amiibo
but from one person to the other because
if you
if your negative if your partner is
negative with you or if there's always
positive right you're not gonna get much
the beauty is that the script and its
subject matter was sort of a litmus test
I think people either close the script
and thought it's not for me or close to
him thought I have to be in this movie
and so you know Ellen Page was one of
those people so when we sat down with
her she was just a kindred spirit she
just was ready for adventure mm-hmm and
I think that was true across the board I
think your scenes with Patricia Clarkson
are pretty terrific she's intense
she's the kind of actor that I always
think of acting as it's like a
percentage of how much you're in it you
know you want to be a hundred percent in
this alternate reality that you've
created but I think a lot of times we're
watching acting it's like someone's at
like 80 90 and that's exceptional acting
but you know things sneak in and Patti
is one of those people who's so good and
so in it that she pulls you in it with
her now the other question for you to
Bret I mean you're wearing three hats
your producer hat your co-writer hat and
your actor hat how do you but you're
running on a kind of adrenaline because
you're so excited to get to tell the
story that even though you've been
shooting you know for 12 hours and it's
now like 4:00 in the morning and you're
rewriting pages and you know that the
longer you keep rewriting the less sleep
you're gonna get it for the next day but
you're you want to make them as good as
you possibly can and so you feel this
it's like energy coursing through you to
do it now spin the bottle these days I
thought what I loved about it was that
these adults wanted to be taken so
seriously in what their their ideals
were but they stood around a play
spin-the-bottle I thought that was kind
of brilliant
that was actually an experience we had
on the road and it was so sincere and
you realized like first of course when
you're getting into it you're like this
is weird I mean come on this is like a
middle school game didn't we get over
the idea of like kissing each other but
then you play the game and the same
thing that happened on the road
happened on set because at some point
those all came in the room and we'd done
it according to the script achill of
times and then Saul walked in and was
like look you guys have been in
character from month now you know who
you are
spin the bottle and see where it lands
for real and play the game and we played
the game for like an hour and a half and
it was enchanting again the same thing
happened which is like at first people
are laughing and it feels a little
awkward and then people open up to each
other and something tender and sincere
and the total opposite of the irony of
our times happens and like by the end of
that experience we were genuinely moved
and became the collective we were
pretending to be and the crew was into
it too I was sitting in my chair and all
of a sudden their grips makeup artist
order I mean the whole crew they wanted
to see who was gonna land on who that
bottle would spin and you never knew so
I suggest we play spin the bottle now we
can do that I play spins only spin the
mic spin the mic didn't mic